take on examines do I hope everyone
found that exercise music hmm oh we push
it back to Tuesday oh all right
never mind
all right we'd talk again about the
things related to the chapter dealing
with the mongols and the east and the
mongols in the West and for the last
couple of days I've entertained this
thought and that thought another thought
and so forth and didn't come up with a
whole lot maybe it's because the chapter
was was well written and wasn't all that
more that needed to be set maybe it was
because I didn't know enough about the
subject well I think I wrote the chapter
I actually just rewrote Pamela Crosley's
chapter there are certain things that
you look at it more broadly and you find
somewhat curious though it's a little
hard to know what to make of it for
example where the Mongols ruled directly
which would be outside of their home
territories in Central Asia Iran and
China the period of Mongol rule is a
period of a pretty high cultural
performance that has a comparatively
little anti mongol feeling or feeling by
the mongols against the indigenous
populations in the areas where they
ruled as overlords which be true of
korea and eastern Anatolia Russia you
have patterns of cooperation that are
roughly similar and in some ways the
areas that where they were where they
did not penetrate are the areas where
they seem to have had the the almost
mythic impact that has attributed them
generally places like Lithuania Eastern
Europe in general mam Luke
Egypt and Japan suggesting that the that
the perception of the Mongols as a as in
force in history is like so many other
things in history variable depending on
where you're looking from and without a
a Mongol authored Mongol central
narrative year almost always confined to
one of these external viewpoints
having said that yeah well what more is
there to say about the Mongols what I
did last time was to talk about non
Mongol things I want to talk about
namely the Mamluks and the changes that
occurred in the Mamluk period that is to
say in the 13th century in the 14th
century that were not generated by the
Mongols but developments that had in a
sense been disguised by the fact that
the that the historical narrative is so
heavily dominated by the fear of the
Mongols you might say something similar
about about Japan where the fear of the
Japanese of the Japanese had of another
Mongol invasion played an important role
in the shaping of the Japanese polity
and yet most of the things that
characterize the later Shogun in Japan
as it emerges are not primarily or even
in any substantial measure attributed to
the Mongols I'd say there's no no
cultural influence or anything like that
so with the Mongols it depends a bit on
what you see depends on where you're
looking from and so what I'm going to
talk about instead of going through a
rundown of what these views might be I'm
going to talk about food I've mentioned
before in this class that food history
is in a state of rapid development lots
of historians are focusing on the
history of food and it has the virtue of
being something that can interest
historians of every period every part of
the world because everybody eats the
degree to which the the subject is study
about my historians depends a lot on
sources but the nice thing about food is
that the sources can be so diverse some
of them will be narrative sources where
you have descriptions of banquets or or
ethnographic comments made by writers
some of them are archaeological where
you actually find the remains of meals
or kitchens or garbage pits some of them
are visual for example when you read
that the that the most important banquet
foods in a 15th century or 16th century
Europe were were Birds and primarily
cranes and herons you can go to
paintings of the period of Rembrandt of
Rembrandt and see
paintings showing the whole parcel of
upper-class Dutch members of some
company at the dining table and you look
at what's on the dining table and you'll
find they're mostly birds with long
curvy necks and you say oh those are the
cranes that they used to eat but what I
want to focus on does relate to the
Mongol period in one sense in our
chapter we we try to draw commonalities
between different societies and
different parts of the world the West
some in the East that change in response
to the Mongol onslaught and for the East
Asia we have a heading that says yo East
Asia emerges in which we sort of look at
the 13th century and end of the 14th
century as a time when you get a
spreading and more a broader generality
of culture particularly associated with
the spread of Confucianism or in the
neo-confucian form which have nothing
whatsoever to do with Mongols
but one of the things that doesn't
really become so homogenized is food in
East Asia Mongol Chinese Korean and
Japanese cuisines are markedly distinct
from each other I would imagine the same
is true if you get down into Vietnam but
I don't know enough about Vietnamese
cooking in its earlier phases to comment
on that but what you have is a
persistence of diversity even as the the
upper classes become more and more
oriented toward similar views whether
those are regret reverence for the
Confucian classics and appraisal of the
qualities of someone to hold official
office as dependent upon their mastery
of the Confucian classics or whether it
is a homogeneity based on the spread of
Buddhist views particularly either in
the Pure Land sect or in the Zen form of
Buddhism Zen in Japan China and China
and I don't remember the Korean word for
the equivalent but at the level of food
they remain rather separate contrast
that with the West a meal in Baghdad or
Rome or Paris or Copenhagen or Amsterdam
say would be pretty much identifiably a
meal regardless of the language spoken
or the particular cultural
characteristics of the society whether
they were
Muslims or Christians or whether Eastern
Christians or Latin Christians there
there are significant variations in
earlier chapter in the book we spoke
about a sort of Mediterranean diet that
emphasized olive oil and seafood and
grain versus a Germanic diet farther to
the north that emphasized dairy products
butter meat and beer instead of the wine
that you would have in the south and as
you'd go over into the Middle East you
have some more variations but by and
large the West has a fairly uniform
notion of a food not surprisingly given
the way in which world history has
slanted in the writing of it by Western
historians a key part of it is cereal
cereal grains and in particular wheat
the West loves its bread and before
wheat was developed enough to really
produce bread well they loved their
porridge you know nothing like a meal to
get you going in the morning or the
afternoon or evening or pretty much any
time of day so you had boiled grain or
baked bread which could either be 11 or
unleavened you had a set of vegetables
and you could put in that boiled grain
or eat along with the bread and by and
large those vegetables are ones that we
would that we would recognize now
there are some vegetables that you had
in classical antiquity and into the
Middle Ages that we don't eat so much
now but it's not it's not
extraordinarily different this is a
cookbook from Imperial Rome by an author
named Apicius it's the best known Roman
cookbook it is supposedly reflects the
Imperial tastes in realm it's in ten
books and when you look at the topics of
the books I'm certainly not going to go
into menus here or recipes because this
particular translation was done by
people who were known to be good cooks
but not particularly good at laughing
therefore if they say it's an
improvement because they can you can use
the recipes but there are perhaps some
lapses in the in the Latin side of it so
in book 6 devoted to foul here are the
chapters ostrich chapter 1 you have
boiled ostrich ostrich stew with boiled
ostrich it's good to have pepper mint
cumin leeks celery seed dates honey
vinegar raisin wine broth a little oil
oil this in the stock kettle you know
put everything in the kitchen and the
kettle with the ostrich and boil until
tender so he of ostrich chapter 2 is
devoted to crane or duck partridge doves
wood pigeon squab and diverse birds
chapter 3 is devoted to a thrush chapter
4 - the fig pepper the fig pecker I
don't know what a fake pecker is chapter
5 - the peacock chapter 6 - the pheasant
Chapter 7 - the goose and chapter 8 -
the chicken and of course the striking
thing here is that the chicken comes
last whereas we would probably assume
that the chicken would come first in
most lists of fowl but there is a
preference implied here for wild birds
over domestic birds so the the goose and
the chicken are at the bottom of the
list peacock and pheasant that come just
before them are domestic sort of in
Roman times and then above that you'll
have wild birds including duck which
seems to hear the more important here is
a wild bird that's book 6 book 7 labeled
sumptuous dishes in this translation it
has 17 chapters the number one the first
one is South womb of cracklings bacon
tenderloin tails and feet and you think
well that pretty much covers the pig but
no because chapter 2 is sows belly
chapter 3 is fig fed pork then you have
chops and stakes than roasts then boiled
in stewed meats then paunch
then loins and kidneys when suspects
that the loins are actually the
testicles then
pork shoulder livers and lungs homemade
sweets I'm not quite sure whether that
is sweetbreads or not
bulbs and toupper and tubers mushrooms
truffles snails and eggs all these are
the same in the same book nothing
wildly I'm understandable although I
must say a few where does it involve
pony where the guy talks about his Feast
of the swelling unctuous teat of a
pregnant sow who cut off and you think
what a disgusting meal but pregnant pigs
were indeed a particular delicacy and
the unborn
you know suckling pig is good but hey
unborn Pig
that's going to be even more more tender
so the swelling on truest heat of the
pregnant sow knew cut off was in fact a
delicacy that charmed people in book
eight you have quadrupeds and here we
have wild boar venison chamois and
gazelle in the same chapter wild sheep
beef and veal kid and lamb pig hair and
dormouse
again the preference here is for the
wild animals or at least they they take
precedence which I am understanding
you'd be preference over the over the
domestic animals so that wild boar is
number one
whereas Pig is number seven and there is
a great question whether in terms of
cuisine
whether people distinguished you know
how what distinction people drew between
boar and pig I was in a restaurant in
Prague a number of years ago that
featured various somewhat unusual meats
and the on the menu it had a dish called
wild boar Jewish style and I thought gee
this sounds kind of strange and so I
asked our host a very right-wing
Catholic gentleman whether he thought
there was some sort of contradiction and
having a pig served Jewish style I think
back of my mind I thought that he was
going to say that this is the way Jews
were served but but he said well what's
the problem I said well bors are pigs
and Jews don't eat pigs and so he had
never heard of that belief so I ordered
the dish and then as I was Ian he said I
see you ordered it and you broke your
law I said well actually I'm not Jewish
I just wanted to see what Jewish style
math and with onions
stood up with onions but you know this
is Roman period and as you go forward
even though the the sources become less
detailed for the West though we do have
some very good information on cooking in
the Islamic caliphate it it stopped
there's not there no big surprises if
there is a unified culture in the sort
of northwest quadrant of the
afro-eurasian landmass that encompasses
Europe the Middle East and North Africa
one of the ways of seeing that is to
look at the a fairly common diet well
throughout the area
there is nowhere near the difference
among the different cuisines whether
we're talking about Persian or Turkish
or French or British I suppose we can
use the word cuisine there there is
nowhere near the difference that you get
among these various cuisines compared to
the difference you would get in East
Asia on the among various cuisines now
the reason I bring this up in this
particular lecture is that I want to
talk a bit about a book that is quoted
in a rather brief section in the chapter
that you are to have read for today and
this is book a book by Paul Buell and
Eugene Anderson it's entitled a soup for
the Khan spelled qan instead of the kha
and that we're more familiar with
what it is is a a cookbook that was
prepared for the descendants of Kubala
hog Kublai Khan was the grandson of
Genghis Khan he was born in 1215 in the
Mongolian steppe land in other words he
sort of the last of his line of the
family to actually grow up in the
Mongolian homeland in the Mongolian
tradition by 1274 the conquest of China
that had been begun by genghis khan and
you know in the same timeframe of the
first invasions of the Middle East in
the second decade of the 13th century by
12 12 74 China had really been conquered
by the Mongols and the Chinese army of
the Mongol armies pushed on into Korea
northern Vietnam then called mmm and
were poised to to invade Japan the
capital for the Mongols was Beijing
which they don't sort of the emergence
of Beijing it pre-exists when I was the
main imperial capital of China it really
comes into its own at this time and
there was a resort area
known as song do which was northward
toward the toward the steppe land toward
Mongolia and that is what becomes the
Xanadu in Coleridge's in Coleridge's
poem the the cookbook that we have for
the ruling family of the of the Khan's
was written by a gentleman with a
Chinese name although it was assumed
that he probably was not a ethnically
exclusively Chinese it's assumed that he
is probably by the editors of this and
translators to assume that he was a
mixed parentage perhaps Chinese and
Turkic of some sort probably not a
Mongol the it's a very very extensive
text this is a 700 page book it has you
know it's woodblock prints
and probably well it's certainly one of
the most extensive cookbooks that we
have from the medieval period and what's
extraordinary is that it is very
specific to the Mongol ruling family it
reflects from time to time some
influences from the Middle East I just
say you have some some food products
that have middle-eastern names or our
revenues in the Middle Eastern dishes
and it reflects some of the tendencies
tendencies from China so you have some
Chinese products and some you know
Chinese medical views but by and large
it appears to reflect the is that this
appease telephone ringing and now you
stop it
so reflects a Chinese view particularly
on the medical side now it is striking
how different the mongol world was from
the worlds of the people whom the
Mongols conquered and this you know
shows up very strikingly in the in the
foods that they consumed Mongolia of
course was primarily down to the present
day
a land of
pastoral herders there is only I think
there's still only one American
fast-food restaurant in Ulaanbaatar the
capital and that is a branch of bidis
Mongolian barbecue which has a
particular kind of cuisine where you
grill meats that are skewered on a long
sort of sword like thing on a on a
propane heated griddle and biddies
Mongolian barbecue bears no relation to
any known Mongolian practice it is a a
Japanese style of cooking that they
decided to name Mongolia named Mongolian
for reasons I don't really know but the
the Mongols had a diet that was
extremely heavy in in meat and animal
products but not notably
in the meat of the horses horse was
considered a delicacy occasionally you
would eat horse on a ceremonial occasion
but by and large horses were too
valuable simply as wealth to to
slaughter and eat so the most common
domestic animal was the Sheep as a meat
animal and pigs which would of course be
extremely common in China were were
seldom eaten they don't have herds of
pigs but when you look at the list of
animal foods contained in the book it is
striking both for its variety and for
the difference between Mongolian notions
of of meat-eating and what you'll have
elsewhere here's a list of the of the
meats of the animal foods the meats that
were eaten in compared with the what I
said earlier about the examples from
Rome sheep no ox sheep gazelle the blue
sheep horse wild horse elephant camel
wild camel bear donkey
Sika deer red deer River deer dog pig
wild boar otter tiger leopard pre
David's beer musk deer mud Jack deer Fox
rhinoceros wolf hair wild cat terrible
calm weasel and monkey there are recipes
for for all these animals in the book
and they're often very specific like Oh
Wolf's had drool or you know a sheep
brain puri or things like that I mean
that's every part of the animal that
gets eaten and when you look at the
travellers who went to Mongolia like
Marco Polo and talked about their eating
they they stress the fact that that
everything is even you know other than
the dung every part of the animal gets
eaten and the bones are not given away
to the dogs until they have been drained
of their marrow we the argument of these
authors is that you know this was not a
food rich country and therefore you you
ate everything that you that you had now
that's the
the the mammals then we get to the
poultry
Swan oriental Swan goose wild goose
crane Eurasian curlew chicken pheasant
eared fowl duck wild duck
Tufted Duck mandarin duck pigeon dove
great bustard collared crow common quail
Sparrow and bunting spellin bunting
these are very small birds and they're
you know I've seen in you know food
markets in Southeast Asia Birds this big
that are you know fried up and made
available so us but small birds were
eaten earlier in Europe though they're
not mentioned in Apicius they could be
caught in Nets fairly easily and don't
toast it up for fish this is an area
that doesn't have any fish and most of
the fish mentioned here are probably
imported from China although that
doesn't make wouldn't make a whole lot
of sense to actually bring them to
Mongolia they're more likely to be one
that came to Beijing itself carp golden
carp Chinese bream white fish yellow
ship fish green fish cheap fish sawfish
mud eel baoyu puffer ski annoyed fish a
bar cool fish good person named P lamb
fish softshell turtle crabs shrimp sea
sea snail trough shells way freshwater
mussels and the prickly sculpin this is
an enormous variety of animal foods that
that are listed in this book I won't go
on and read all of the fruits and all
the vegetables or all the spices but
what you have here is
variety in which probably two-thirds or
more of the items mentioned would be
unfamiliar to palates at the western end
of the Mongol Empire this despite the
fact that you'd had you know a thousand
years closer to two thousand years of
the Silk Road of exchange of products
going across Eurasia they it just points
out when you look at the of these
various products that everything does
not does not travel the author of the
book was a specialist on on medicine so
he was particularly concerned with the
medical indicators for each of these
dishes so he has a list here of the
decent the dispositions that would be
cured by different things so donkeys had
gruel that cures apoplexy of vertigo
debility of hand and foot annoying pain
of extremities and trouble in speaking
yeah well are any of those diseases you
know I have some problems with my hands
and feet and trouble in speaking
sometimes and occasionally I guess
annoying pain in my extremities I've had
vertigo once maybe I should have donkeys
head rule I mean no it's it's
interesting the degree to which the the
medical section of the book is not
oriented toward pathogens but oriented
toward in dispositions things that that
we would not necessarily consider part
of a medical regime that there you know
there are states of the person that you
might
want to correct in some fashion but you
wouldn't necessarily go to a physician
to do it
donkey that was donkeys head rule but
donkeys meat soup it cures wind mania
and depression and pacifies heart qi
wind mania and depression your wind
Manian know if it's wind mania and
depression yes when the wind blows you
go
that's wind mania and wind depression is
where blows the other direction you say
Oh feel terrible so then that's when you
have donkeys meat soup Fox meat gruel it
cures infantile convulsion epilepsy
spiritual confusion in the state speech
and inappropriate singing and laughing
so you know if you get a singing or a
laughing fit you want to head right for
the Fox meat gruel on the other hand
bear meat gruel cures the various twins
evil foot Chi numbness insensitivity and
v flack civet e's flaccidity x' tendon
the tendon and muscle spasms since it's
very hard to know what these industries
and dispositions are without you know
coming at it from the point of view of
chinese medicine you don't know quite
where to go with this except that the
the food's themselves are so suggestive
a kudzu starch gruel hemp seed congee
black donkey skin soup wild pig meat
broth otter liver gruel
then there's a section that tells you
about the things that you cannot eat
with each other that just don't go well
together if one has taken Chinese
foxglove one must not eat prepared
stinking elm if one has taken false
hellebore one must not eat orangutan
meat which is not mentioned as one of
the animals that the mongols ate and
there are no orangutangs anywhere
remotely close to mongolia if one has
taken China route one must not eat
vinegar if one has taken Chinese
asparagus one must not eat carp and
there's a whole list of those then you
have stuff that appears to be extremely
practical benefits and harmfulness of
foods if flower has a stinking smell it
cannot be eaten if fresh ingredients are
discolored and stink they cannot be
eaten if broth is old and food is watery
it cannot be eaten if one boils meat and
it does not change color it cannot be
eaten if the various meats are not
slaughtered they should not be eaten
though that's a very curious one because
it suggests that that the method of
slaughtering is a is an important factor
if the various meats smell and are
spoiled they cannot be eaten the various
brains cannot be eaten any sacrificial
meat which moves on its own cannot be
eaten
rule out all that wild oh yes probably
so that probably is to keep away from
carrion
neither horses liver and our cows liver
can be eaten a hair with closed eyes
cannot be eaten one cannot use mulberry
wood fire for roasting meat hair meat
should not be eaten during the second
month avoid storing various meat Jerky's
in rice there is poison 700 pages of
this pithy advice on eating designed to
inform the court of the Mongols what is
striking how little overlap you find in
this between what's here and what is on
the Chinese restaurant menu that you
look at when you're doing takeout
ordering it's it's a different it's a
different world and of course the dairy
products which are which I haven't
talked about here are ones that are
comparatively rare in Chinese cooking of
that era fermented mares milk is almost
a staple for for the Mongols although
they also had fermented other milk they
had fermented camel's milk as well but
fermented mares milk even though they
didn't eat the horses they would
particularly during the spring foaling
season when they had a lot of milk that
was the preferred time to consume
fermented mares milk
there are a lot of beverages listed but
they are not alcoholic beverages the you
know herb teas of the most remarkable
diversity and so forth and so on
okay so the Mongols rule a tremendous
area that they have certain food
practices and certain food preferences
that don't appear to have had much
impact outside the mongol society itself
although by mongol here probably i
should include Central Asian Turkic
because the distinction culturally
between the Mongol tribes and the
Turkish people's who became amalgamated
into the Mongol army in the course of
the conquest is not a particularly
profound distinction but it's it it's
indicative of of the fact that the the
Mongols though they set up a enormous
empire of great importance for world
history did not create a cultural model
if you look at at comparisons you could
say well did the Arabs set up a cultural
model from Morocco to Central Asia when
they carried out the conquests that
established Islam in that in that region
if you went back to a to an Arabian
cookbook of the time of the Prophet it's
not clear that you would find a very
direct connection with what comes after
the empires form in other words the
Arabs may have been like the Mongols
they may have eaten one way when they
were in Arabia and then taken on the
practices of the people they conquered
as they spread the problem with the
Islamic era cookbooks is that they
represent the cuisine of the of the
Abbasid Caliphate and what we know about
the food practices of the Arabs in
Western Arabia at the time of the
Prophet is much more limited and is
contained to a substantial degree in
hadith questions of what did the Prophet
eat or what did he approve of eating or
not eating and yet even so there is
little indication that you had a a
profound difference I think you had a
great increase in variety as you spread
out from Arabia but an Arab cuisine may
have had some sort of broader impact qua
Arab cuisine qua Arabian desert cuisine
dates for example did the Romans spread
a cuisine or did Alexander the Great and
the Greeks spread the cuisine very hard
to to affirm that because these are
empires they're expanding within a
section of the world that already had
had a great deal of interaction over
long periods of time so that products
that were available on you know in the
Roman Empire or the Alexandrian Empire
were products that have become available
through through commerce long before
that time wine for example the spread of
wine drinking is prior to the
to the spread of the Greek culture or
later the Roman one exception might be
the Roman penchant for for garam which
basically is spoiled fish sauce made out
of sort of rotting anchovies which is
probably the closest thing to it is
Worcestershire sauce which is also made
out of anchovies which you don't want to
know if you're someone who doesn't like
anchovies on their pizza or anchovies on
their Caesar salad and then you read and
you find that their anchovies and the
Worcestershire sauce the Worcestershire
sauce tastes so good but but the Romans
put garam on everything there was the
ketchup of the day and they exported it
and garam containers have been found all
over the Mediterranean area and that was
a Roman specialty but it's one it's one
thing so I would I would say that the
the question of the Mongols is that they
they conquer in an area without leaving
a profound trace on the area even if
they had a tremendous impact on its
history this has been examined in many
other ways for example the the
comparative lack of Mongolian words that
show up in in languages in areas that
the Mongols ruled the comparative
absence of mongolian names or whether
either individual names of tribal names
in areas of the mongols
occupied and had under their control for
a century or so the Mongol the Mongol
foot landed heavily but left very little
footprint just thought of that
well nice image you know foot land
heavily oh and it really sort of singles
the Mongols out now let me turn to this
issue of East Asia in particular and the
and the fact that not just that the
Mongols did not have a impact on
homogenizing the food culture of East
Asia but that the the spread of those
things that did transform in some degree
the the political and intellectual and
ideological worlds of East Asia such as
neo-confucianism and Pure Land and Zen
Buddhism that they did not homogenized
the food regimes either because Japanese
Korean and Chinese cuisine have remained
strikingly distinct except for the
common consumption of rice not
surprisingly the you know the data we
have on the spread of rice farming from
southern China and Vietnam into broader
areas is often talked about by world
historians as a major move but in fact
in northern China other grains were used
more than rice and in Japan used to you
had buckwheat being used extensively
in areas where rice to not grow so rice
it has a certain geographical
restriction to it but even the way rice
is cooked will differ from place to
place so the Korean cooking of rice and
iron pot will be different from the way
it was cooked in in China say in Korean
cuisine according to descriptions of
eating etiquette you do not pick up your
rice bowl and hold it up to your face
and eat from it you leave it on the
table and you eat from it that way
whereas the Chinese and Japanese would
both hold the rice bowl up a table
setting in Korea would always include a
spoon and chopsticks
you know silver chopsticks if you have a
an elegant banquet but the information
we have on seating at banquets portrays
the Korean model in a somewhat different
fashion than the Chinese model this is
something that I've never really seen
written up on a comparative basis is the
the the organization of banquets but it
happened to be something for which a lot
of information is available on a on a
cross-cultural basis so for example one
of the descriptions of a mongol banquet
in china would say that you know the the
great Han sits at a table that is higher
than anybody else's table and then below
him slightly below him are other members
of his family and then below them are
and pretty soon you figure well the
Great Khan must be about 30 feet in the
air because everybody is below everybody
else until you finally get down below
and the
point was that supposedly everybody
could see the great hog and observe him
at the banquet including the forty
thousand onlookers who were there just
looking at the banquet you can get a
contrast here with the say the
banqueting practices of Baghdad under
the under the Ambassador caliphate
because they're the the Calif was on one
side of a curtain and you nobody could
see the Kayla feet but he could hear the
conversation and if he chose contribute
to it but nobody got to see him eat but
then you had various rules of etiquette
that we have details on for example no
one is supposed to eat very much because
if you ate a great deal it would
indicate that you found the food more
interesting than the presence of the
Calif sorry is supposed to to go to the
banquet look at the screen or the
curtain behind which the Calif was
presumed to be sitting and simply play
with your food because you were so in
awe of the Imperial presence unless and
here was an important exception that's
listed in the you know the book we have
on this etiquette unless you were known
for to be a great pig if you were famous
for overeating then you were expected to
to go and make an absolute display of
yourself but gobbling up everything
around so that you would amuse the Calif
now how the Calif saw this weather he's
kind of peeking through a hole I don't
know but certainly the ranks of people
you know who sits where with respect to
the presence of the of the Calif
you know that will be spelled out just
as it is in these descriptions of of
Mongol banqueting and descriptions that
we have Oh Korean banqueting I never
attended a banquet with the Shah of Iran
but I had friends who did before the
Iranian Revolution they said and I did
go to two you know official banquets in
Iran from time to time and there the the
protocol was that you stand around and
talk for a long time and then presently
they open the doors and you were invited
into long tables that have myriad bowls
and plates full of food on them and
there are no chairs and no tables and
you grab the as much food as you can as
quickly as you can and the tables are
pretty much stripped of food in a matter
of five minutes or so and then you stand
there and you eat your food and then you
go directly home it's the very last
thing that happens on the occasion now
and a very reminiscent of descriptions
that you have of of triumphs after a
battle where all of the booty is laid
out on a table and the soldiers are
invited in to grab what they can and you
have this image of you know they fell on
such-and-such like like Turks falling on
a table full of booty because you know
you get some coins or a nice helmet or a
sword or something like that but friends
mine who went to the two Imperial
banquets said that you have the same
thing where you had a big table long
tables full of food and then the Shah
and the Empress were sitting at a table
on the far side of the room
having a dinner and you were you know
the audience
the banquet guests were to grab their
food and eat and nobody was allowed to
have their back to the royal couple so
you're standing there eating and pray so
I presume not eating too much unless of
course you're a pig and you're observing
the Shah and his and his Empress dining
presumably on good Parisian cuisine
which was the taste of the path of a
family it's just striking how little
change there was from what you find
described in etiquette books of the of
the ninth century and on the whole when
you get into food history one of the
things that that sometimes strikes you
is how persistent food ways are and how
reluctant people are to give up their
their food habits some of the more
variable practices are those that you
find in in Western Europe and I think
that's not not in terms of the of the
foods that are eaten but in terms of the
eating style I think that's partly
because the Western Europeans were
barbarians and you know ate and crude in
unseemly fashion and gradually developed
better manners but older societies that
had ideas of etiquette ideas of how to
carry out a banquet were much greater
stability in the in the in the food way
Department in Korea Korea is not the
only part of East Asia that relishes
eating dogs but Korea has developed dog
eating to a more refined level dogs are
even particularly in southern China in
Taiwan it's called fragrant meat but in
Korea you have special restaurants set
aside for the serving of dog a special
breed of dog is Britt is raised as a
meat animal and is completely distinct
from the from dogs that are raised as
pets and our esteemed as pets dog eating
is primarily a summer you know
dish because it was felt to balance the
know the seasonal effects of the summer
was very important in in humoral
medicine where you you eat things that
are supposed to compensate for changes
in the in the weather or in your own
bodily balance so if you had hot and
cold wet and dry then if you were if you
were in a very dry state you would want
to eat wet foods and if you were in a
hot state you'd want to eat cold foods
and this becomes fairly you know fairly
well entrenched in the in the in the
food way in traditions in Iran for
example you can look at cookbooks that
will say that you all say if you make a
dish like fess and John which is what
it's just wonderful it's a stew made up
of pomegranate syrup ground walnuts
onion and and what we would call chicken
the proper recipe calls for rooster
because this is a warming dish that is
meant to be eaten in the winter when
you're balancing the cold of the
atmosphere and a rooster is you know the
meat of a rooster produces a warm effect
on the humor whereas the meat of a hen
produces a cooling effect
you know it's where these customs come
from it's hard to say and I'm not always
sure quite what the implication is
though I do recall vividly traveling one
night from nesha poor to Sam's bar in
order to spend the night with some Peace
Corps friends because there was a
military group that had a movie and we
would get to see a movie and sleep on
the floor and was worth traveling
hundred kilometers in the middle of the
night to see and on the way our driver
stopped at a dark adobe hut beside the
road where he apparently customarily
stopped in order to drink a great
quantity of vodka which he proceeded to
do but there was a marvelous woman there
who you know a great florid woman of
hard to describe her but the man had
ordered rooster and she took the
roosters head and sort of pulling her
her hijab partially over her mouth she
would nibble on the on the crest on
their own the roosters head with tiny
little bites are and it was I'm sure
intended to be something really really
really sexy but and but the idea of
eating the roosters head as a heating
thing you know I'm ready to eat the
Roosters head and you know what's your
word for rooster in English hahaha I
don't know it's a when you run into
something like that you're struck by the
by both the persistence of foodways but
also the impenetrability of of some of
them
so I'm told that in that dog eating is a
very special thing in Korea there is a
great debate of the time of the World
Cup in Seoul whether they should suspend
dog eating in order not to offend people
and other people said well the Americans
don't give up eating beef when the
Indians come for the Olympics so why
should we give up eating dog then you
got to Japan where you have a totally
different cuisine in which there you
know anything that lives in the ocean is
eaten but very few land animals are
eaten and you don't have herd animals
you don't have by and large you don't
have traditionally the eating of lamb or
or pork or you have some beef eaten but
usually superannuated plow animals
rather than animals have been raised for
this purpose now all of this has changed
and the if there is one world empire
that is changing the food ways of the
world it's the United States and one of
the things of the last let's say
post-world war ii era has been the
phenomenal shrinkage of the variety of
food ways in the world as economic
and sort of pseudo-scientific or
health-related issues have pushed
everybody toward eating beef so that the
Japanese and the Koreans now eat
enormous amounts of beef whereas before
they ate none to speak up push them to
consume milk and milk products push them
to consume more wheat and basically
there's a a Western diet essentially an
American diet that is taking over the
world in a very striking way
particularly when you compare it with
earlier episodes of imperial expansion
whether economic or political so the
British did not spread their diet
thanked fortune around the world
the French did not spread theirs and
certainly in many parts of the world are
still holding out against the
globalization that we are currently
experiencing based on a sort of American
practices but it is a a daunting
phenomenon and one that I think makes it
all the more important for us to to
study the history of food the history of
etiquette the history of banqueting and
things of this sort in order to see what
they can tell us about about you know
what what really changes in the world
and how those changes come about a
number of years ago I was asked by the
librarian of law school to come over and
take a look at several large boxes of
books and Arabic that they wanted to
dispose of and I certainly was in no
position to go through you know five or
six large boxes of Arabic books and tell
them what was what was importantly
appeared to be primarily books of
basically law books from various Arab
countries that they no longer wanted but
somehow my eyes lit upon a book entitled
etiquette that was the it had the title
on the cover in French and in Arabic it
had it much more elaborate title and I
plucked it out and I said well this
looks interesting the the book was
published in 1898 I believe not in Cairo
but in how lamb which was a spa that
wealthy Chiron's and foreigners would go
to to take the waters it's now been
spoiled by a steel mill and it was a
very very interesting book on etiquette
by an arab writer who well by an
egyptian writer he was probably albanian
my family background but it was an
egyptian writer who was trying to
explain to egyptians how westerners live
and it was a very interesting
introduction to the book he said these
people have come to our land and
observed us and studied us they know how
we get married they know how we do
circumcision ceremonies they know they
know more about what we do than we do
and we don't know anything about
however they have no respect for us
because we do these funny things that to
say we are objects of anthropological
observation we dress in peculiar and you
know unacceptable ways and so forth and
so on and therefore if you want to be
taken seriously by the Europeans you
have to study them as closely as they
study you you have to learn their their
their customs their foods their
banqueting practices all of the aspects
of etiquette and daily life that they
have studied with regard to you you have
to learn so that you can act like them
because only then will they respect you
yeah you you cannot wear a keffiyeh and
expect anyone to to respect you you have
to look like a European but beyond
looking like a European you have to know
how to act like one and it proceeds over
several hundred pages to describe
exactly how Europeans behave clearly
based upon upon close observation so
there's a chapter on the dinner party
what happens at quote the dinner party
says well you know initially their
beverages and people people talk about
this on that then they sit down at a
table and the food is served and
everyone falls silent and then as they
have as they reach the point where they
have satisfied their appetite
conversation resumes but now instead of
being dispersed it's now centered around
the table and everyone participates the
same conversation until they rise from
table you know there's more detail than
that but it it accurately describes the
dinner party in my apartment
and and yep
utterly different from everyone sitting
on the floor around a tablecloth that's
covered of food and you as soon as you
finish you get up and you and you go
somewhere else and wash your hands I
mean not only different from a
traditional Arab way of of consuming a
meal there's a chapter a brief chapter
on the honeymoon
you know what Europeans do after they
the marriage and the honeymoon because
you know the Europeans describe the
Egyptian marriages so now we describe
the you know how to ride in the carriage
say you know do not put your arm on the
back of the seat if you're next to a
woman because even though you think it's
on the back of the seat she won't think
it's on the back of the seat that's sort
of it and the heart of the book is
recipes it's it's the description of
foods so that you know what the
Europeans eat and striking in this list
of foods and recipes are little tipped
in illustrations that show you how to
carve every every food that they must
come from a previously published work
probably French how do you carve a
rabbit how do you carve this and that
and it's a book it's a book that I found
particularly interesting for the reasons
that I've talked about in this lecture
but then when I brought it to the
attention of various Arab friends I
found that they were extremely offended
by the book and I thought nobody should
know about this book this book should
disappear it should never have been
written because it says that we should
be like Europeans and we are Arabs we
are completely different from Europeans
we however do buy our suits from very
good London suit makers we do go to
upper-class schools we do go to dinner
parties but we go as errors in this
special Arab way and if it's a sort of
sharpen in my mind this this degree to
which etiquette and food provide a lens
for looking at cultural interaction
looking at the impact of Empire looking
at the persistence and reassertion of
diversity under changing political and
intellectual influences and all this
adds up to a to a peon in favor of a
food history and etiquette history and
banqueting history